foreign
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast on
the show is my very good friend Kya raw
she is an international best-selling
author she wrote a book called The
Sophia code which you're going to hear a
ton about and all of the ascended
masters that she channeled for this book
she is a divine feminine speaker of
sovereignty she promotes sourcing your
own power having your own sovereignty in
this life for your energy and your power
of what you can really be and so the
episode just had a lot to do with what
our real potential is as human beings
and the things that have kept that down
so we talk about dark energies nefarious
agendas you know the way that that
manifests in this reality and the way
that we experience that so this is an
insanely inspiring and empowering
episode that should hopefully lead you
to a place where you feel like you're
capable of more than you've ever
imagined anything you want you can have
I hope you enjoy it I hope you are
inspired and empowered please hit the
Subscribe button the Bell is for
notifications when the episode comes out
you know let me know your thoughts have
any of you read the Sophia code have you
had any miraculous things happen in your
life have you grown and evolved in ways
that you didn't see coming or that have
been powerful I'd love to know so enjoy
the episode we connected so deeply on
Egypt and I told you I was going to
Egypt in February and then you had said
oh my god
um
Egypt's been popping up for me so much
lately and you were dealing with this
other scenario with Egypt and and then
all of a sudden you were like telling a
story about this like going into the
past with sort of someone that you were
kind of working through some things with
that you had lived other lives with and
you were like and then you were telling
the story and you go and then you were
there and you were doing this and I was
like wait a second
what did you just say so I don't know
just speak to sort of the connection
that you felt and that and and in
ancient history and and and sort of
maybe where we're at now in this in the
world and what's going on like but maybe
I guess to pare it down let's just talk
about our connection and how we
connected so deeply
yes you know it I do a lot of inner work
like constant and
um one of the deepest forms of inner
work that I've really tackled over the
past few years is past life healing
which I also consider parallel life
healing in in Quantum reality and so it
was just a week before meeting you that
I had seen you for the first time
and uh in in a pre in another lifetime
where we had connected and
I wasn't gonna bring anything up about
it I was I felt pretty awkward about the
whole thing because we were meeting for
dinner for the first time but it
actually
um kind of helped me relax in meeting
you for the first time
um I was
um it just helped me
relax into that this was a connection
that you know in the divine feminine
lineages that we have been you know
connecting with each other's heart as
Soul family across time and space and
in that lifetime
um myself and many members on my team
were
um we had created a a temple and a
mystery School consecrated to hathor
teachings and
um
we were making a significant impact on
the culture at the time
um we focused primarily on women's
empowerment and the divine feminine and
what was unique about our mystery school
is we didn't really rely so much on the
patriarchy for our funding we had a lot
of ways of creating resources through
the Arts and education that really made
our mystery School stand out and that's
actually how you heard about us in your
own life in in ancient Egypt and um and
you you got involved you were inspired
by the work we were doing although from
a distance and then when our Temple was
attacked and burned to the ground and
most of us were killed
um which took me and my team members a
whole
journey of reconciliation and inner work
to uncover that for multiple people on
my team
um
well anyways I escaped with a lot of the
children and it was
to you that I ended up finding my way
and the two of us found homes for these
children and then got me on a boat to
some place really safe and
um you know it just goes to show that
the divine feminine has
continued to be oppressed and persecuted
and censored throughout many timelines
on this planet and
um and that's you know why I love
reconnecting with you and so many other
women and souls men as well and of
course non-binary individuals that are
connected to the divine feminine
movement
um I really believe this is our lifetime
to shine and rise above the persecution
and the oppression of of you know
multiple past Dark Ages
so and I believe hathor's teachings are
really essential for us in Rising above
in our sovereignty during you know this
time on the planet
um then that's why she's included in the
Sofia code
yeah um
so thanks again sharing that whole story
I mean honestly it just like humbles me
so much like and it just makes me
excited too like this is like such an
overwhelming feeling I have I'm like
we're not gonna get killed this time
that's gonna get it done and actually I
just did an interview with uh Lindsay
milis who does um she's a midwife and
she's very spiritual and she told me
that
um back in like the 1400s that there
were nine million women
killed
for essentially being
powerful and to use their power and
that's that's the nine million that you
know that they tell us to believe like
we don't even know how many millions
more remember the I remember I had
dinner with you that night and then
which was so wonderful and then I went
home and I've always been very drawn to
Isis and um we're gonna get into into
Sophia code and and writing it in the
process and then I really want to get
into obviously the the ascended masters
in their message but
um but Isis is the one I've always been
drawn to and I went into a long long di
tribe about sort of like all the
different things that have drawn me to
Isis and so I went home and I read the
Isis key code in the Sofia code yeah and
it's the direct transmission
um that you received the channeling of
about her life and to her telling it and
I read it and it and then I I was going
to bed and it was already late because
again it was a four-hour dinner and I
remember telling the ambitious you read
that after dinner I remember that after
dinner I was just so drawn and then I
don't remember me telling you but I told
you I I didn't tell you right away
because I just didn't know like how far
how how much to go and what to ask and
what sort of to like pull from you yet
as we were new friends but I ended up
telling you that I was I went to bed
that night and I was freezing I had to
sweatpants and sweatshirt on and I went
to the bathroom before I went to bed and
I was like got it I got into bed and I
was like I am so cold and I laid down I
pulled all the blankets I had three
blankets over me and I never took my
sweatpants and sweatshirt off and I
never got hot and I mean I am a hot
sleeper so I keep my bedroom really cold
and I keep minimal amount of layers on
and um and I remember what you said and
you said it's from The Many Lives of you
know your your soul is is thawing from
how many times you were murdered for
your your your magic in your power power
and your and and just what you're
capable of and that was like such a
powerful thing to say
yeah and it's amazing that you so
intuitively could feel isis's call you
know to you for for you to really embody
your divine feminine and your just
overall Sovereign power in this lifetime
um because that was who was your main
key code Mentor in that lifetime in
Egypt it was Isis and uh even though you
are supporting us at a hathor temple
um
yeah so it's
I feel as though individuals that are
connected to Isis have they make such an
incredible impact in their Divine
Purpose whether they intend to or not
because Isis keeps us really focused on
um completing the tasks of our Divine
Purpose fulfilling the Angelic mission
for which we we've been sent and even if
we may not know exactly how we're making
a difference she keeps guiding us until
we just until we fully recognize the
difference the impact we are are already
making and I feel like that's something
that you've been really coming into over
the past few years like
well it's an honor to be any part of
your process but you you know we talked
a lot about that like your choice and
you know to impact Consciousness and you
keep showing up to that choice
to write the Sofia code was really
showing up and that whole process so
um can you give some insight into what
that process was like and how long that
took and the experience of it I don't
know why I just feel very emotional
right now like I have tears in my heart
yeah
it's uh
unexpected it took me seven years to
channel the Sofia code because every
word that was channeled had to work on
me first and
um when the vision that I share and the
preface of the Sofia code was given to
me uh to you know Channel it to write
this book for the Divine mother I was a
broken person I was you know I was
shattered by what I had survived and so
every teaching every Divine genome
activation every
Step Closer towards the ascended masters
I had to believe that I was worthy of it
that I was worthy of the gift of being
given I had to rebuild my self-esteem
and I had to allow these extremely
powerful crystalline teachings to move
me from such extreme trauma into a place
of
deep reconciliation with myself I
wouldn't say
um
you know I went into a space of Serenity
in the process because I'm still working
on that
but what I what I I have managed to do
is to come into the full connection with
my higher self and and learn how to say
yes to embodying that higher
self-consciousness just a little bit
more every day and and
so it was a lot of time in seclusion I
did not uh just say no to a lot of
parties in my 30s
um and that's okay in our 40s we can do
them all yeah right
celebrate all the hard work of our 30s
yeah
um and uh and I spent a lot of time
sometimes between 12 to 14 hours a day
in a writing room and meditation
um yoga listening writing rewriting
because every time the teachings would
come in I could only accept them as as
much as my Consciousness was ready to
receive them right and then as they
would work on me then the ascendo
Masters would come back and they'd be
like okay and now here's the next like
the download on what we've given you and
so there were there were many
um versions of the Sophia code until I
knew it had crystallized into how I
could best serve it and uh and the last
year of of writing it happened actually
at Mount Shasta California which is
where I received the vision originally
to to channel the book and so that last
year I also was constantly in ceremony I
had a home by the national forest with a
view of the mountain and I would go out
I would make offerings every day I pray
at my medicine wheel pray at all the
altars that I created
um
the water ceremonies
you know it was just constantly hiking
in the mountains to connect with the
ascendant Masters connect with Telos
which is the Lemurian city of Light
Within Mount Shasta the the people of
Telos are extremely powerful and
grounded they helped me really ground
what a Cosmic transmission the Sofia
code
um is so it was
you know
I was
eating in a very strict diet drinking a
lot of water from the mountain like when
I left Mount Shasta it was
after the Sofia goat was published it
was like coming back to Earth or
something like I was just so focused in
that Heavenly realm with that mountain
it was um it was a real powerful journey
to go on and then the journey began all
over again once I left the mountain
because I had to share it with the world
and return to the world of people and
all the things that come along with
people being human sometimes that takes
it's it takes a long time yeah I feel
like I'm yeah and right now it's almost
been seven years so it's almost like
another seven year Journey yeah they say
we go in seven year Cycles yeah right
how can you can you draw a parallel
between because I think it's a very
interesting parallel to draw with your
experience with the ascended masters and
receiving the information but working on
you first and how that can parallel like
on normal let's just call it normal
person's life that's not receiving
necessarily or know they're receiving
that information but sort of the uh
someone else's growth that is not that
doesn't have that exact mission to bring
such deep information such esoteric
information such old information back
like what how do you draw a parallel
because that feels so real like we can't
meet someone at a level higher than we
are like you know the that kind of
analogy how how can someone take extract
that experience you had with writing a
Sofia code and getting the information
with their own life and and growth
yeah so those key code initiations that
were given to us in the Sophia code even
if you read them just once they initiate
direct Mentor relationships with the
ascendant Masters and so that was a
promise that the ascended masters of the
Sofia Dragon tribe which is a specific
High Council
um
oh the Divine mother assembled for the
Sofia code movement and these ascended
masters are just so available they're
just they're ready and waiting for us to
believe that we're worthy of them being
spiritual guides for us and so
um I find that overcoming the worthiness
factor is often the biggest piece for
light workers and and just believing
that a master of like would actually be
interested in our daily human life and
the truth is they absolutely they
absolutely are and mother Mary who we're
focusing on this year
is one of the most amazing spiritual
guides for that because she she shares
in the Sofia code like everything about
your daily life is important to me it
matters to me Isis talks about that too
in the Sofia code because where else
does ascension happen it happens in our
relationships it happens in our family
it happens in our businesses it happens
and how we show up every day to life
whether we show up or not and so I think
people have a skewed idea about what the
incentive Masters are interested in
they're interested in us and waking us
up in our within our daily life not
extracting us from our daily life
because this is where we make the
greatest impact
um and so we we created a curriculum
called the Stargate one curriculum and
it walks you through every chapter of
the Sofia code multiple classes and it
teaches you how to kind of it's
simultaneously let go and allow these
cinemasters to step in and start guiding
you and mentoring you and um beyond your
understanding
um and how to also identify the signs
and the practices that you can just
easily incorporate into your daily life
like creating an altar that you visually
connect with of like hey that's my
intention for today it's sovereignty or
empowerment or I wanna feel closer to
Isis or mother Mary and you know you
just place a picture there you place a
you know a statement or intention and
it's like that works I mean I know you
know that but it's showing your
subconscious what you want to focus on
and what we focus on expands in our life
why are they interested in us why are
the ascended masters what is the
significance what is our significance we
are at pivot all the time in in human
history for our species most of our
species is in a state of Amnesia and
cannot remember how many actual resets
we've gone through how many Global
disasters how much are issues has been
enslaved and persecuted and oppressed
and so the ascended masters
um you know they they come in to this
Matrix they live these exceptional
Avatar level lifetimes uh to re to
mirror back to us our true Sovereign
potential but there's you know there's
only so much they can do because in one
lifetime because it there has to be a
large enough Collective Awakening
for us to break free and Quantum Leap to
an to a new paradigm of liberation
from from these unseen yet extremely
Insidious forces that continue to
do what they're doing to humanity and so
the ascended masters want our
sovereignty they want for us to take our
Awakening seriously and to consider that
we know religion has attempted to
separate us from our Divinity very
purposefully for a very long time
because it is our Divinity that has the
power to wake up within this Matrix and
to decide to unplug from all of this
programming that's keeping us separated
from one another and and separated from
our our creative power to to birth a new
paradigm based in sovereignty based in
light and based in our true potential
um and so
they specialize in how to recover from
trauma
and then also of course once you
stabilize from the collective trauma and
the viral programming
um you you have the opportunity to
actually take in their teachings and
start to embody your higher self embody
a different uh Your Divine Consciousness
which is like an operating system that
over time
you're going to unplug from every last
illusion that you've been plugged into
with the Matrix programming so that's
what they're all about they're but they
can't do it for us
and that's why they're ascended Master
that's why I only work with these
particular sending Masters because they
are all about sovereignty and all about
us doing our own work Opening Our Own
Hearts taking this like this journey
um everybody's individual Journey counts
and if enough Hearts awaken if enough of
us accept that we are sovereign and
divine
we will no longer need these oppressive
experiences for our spiritual awakening
humanity is unconsciously addicted to
being oppressed to stimulate its
Spiritual Awakening
is there a critical mass
percentage I feel like I've heard about
that is that true I feel that very
deeply I mean I'm not going to throw out
like some random number but I I have
seen in many visions that and I believe
is happening in many ways right now I I
really do I think technology has allowed
a certain cross-section of the
population to awaken uh in an
accelerated way
um I think it's a bit of a hot mess
um because there's a lot of people
searching and and not really knowing
where to look and and there's a
restructure happening within their lives
whenever there's when there's a
transition it's like Things Fall away
and have to be rebuilt and that's the
process yeah there's a lot of chaos
right now in in that kind of like you
said the melting down of of disengaging
I mean what happened over the past few
years was really surprising that level
of Oppression
um and lockdowns actually caused a lot
of people to start
uh railing red pills on YouTube in the
middle of the night and so we actually
do have a large cross-section of
humanity that is waking up so these are
conversations that we couldn't have oh
10 years ago like no way I mean I
remember talking with my girlfriends and
being like I'm on an island man like
nobody who are we going to talk to like
what how do we nobody thinks like this
and you know there was nowhere to go
with these conversations and they were
by all means not going to happen on a
podcast because like you know it's so
out there it will be hard to resonate
with mainstream America but I think that
there's definitely
they're definitely an awaking which
leads me to I want you to elaborate a
little bit on the amnesia I mean I've
felt that and I've experienced that I've
even had my own experience in a in a
psilocybin Journey about having so much
information in the field that I couldn't
handle it and I'm like as I came back to
being human I I was I realized why I
couldn't why there's Amnesia because
also if you fully embody the reality
that we actually what we really are it's
hard to play this game so like talk
about this Amnesia Gap and this Matrix
or this this reality that we're living
in I love that you said it's hard to
play this game explain why because we're
here to birth a new game
and that's what's the most terrifying
for for most humans is is creating
something that has never been created
before in a truly Sovereign Paradigm
where everyone is 100 embodying their
Divinity that is not playing like that's
never happened before I mean it's
happened in previous Golden Ages on the
planet hundreds of thousands of years
ago but it's been a hot minute there's
been a really intense Interstellar War
over the future of humanity that's been
raging for quite some time on this
planet and
it's um the need is real for us to start
envisioning what a truly Sovereign
Paradigm of truly awakened
beings awakened to the truth of their
Divinity because if you're awakened to
the truth of your Divinity there's
nothing you can't do that's right
there's nothing you can't do it's
Divinity Divinity created all it is so
you know that's that is the end game for
Humanity that the ascended masters are
are attempting to you know doing their
best to reveal to us is Sophia code and
of course other Pathways of Awakening on
the planet that are available right now
and yeah I love that you said this game
because you are only allowed to get so
far in the Matrix end game there's
there's a ceiling there I mean unless
you want to like you know
totally sell your soul that's a
different story and do people sell their
soul oh yes every day
how does that come to someone to sell
their soul like I feel like this is
something you see a lot more in
entertainment and music and you look at
these satanic possible Satanic rituals
which they sure look pretty satanic that
are happening during
um
Super Bowl or you know uh cons you know
uh music awards shows and you see what's
going on it's like there is definitely
there's definitely an awareness to this
Dynamic so
can you do you know what is happening
where people sell their soul and why
they do and how they do it well a lot of
them end up
um
having to give in to the blackmail
that they and that they walked right
into
and that was definitely a part of what I
survived as a child were
um
how they use and only human trafficking
how to use children for blackmail
purposes and so you get one video of
someone doing something with a child and
forget it that's they are they are in
for life
you know and uh they own you and they
make you do those things then they say
this is what you're wearing and this is
what this song is going to be and sing
it sing it sing it or else I believe
that over it's already starting we
haven't seen anything yet though
I believe in the next three years
hopefully sooner three to four years
we're gonna see
the whole world is going to understand
on how
deeply everything about our reality is
actually programmed literally programmed
at the highest level
and you know all you have to do is look
at who is on the guest list of you know
oh no that the the flight list of
Epstein Island and you you just start to
realize like there is nothing sacred
every every If people really knew how
many uh corporations are actually
involved universities hospitals how
elaborate and sophisticated the system
is it's um
it's going to completely change the
world to discover what's really
happening it already is
um so
what do you think will push that over
the goal line
I think it's going to be people's
ability to grow up
so that it can actually understand and
accept that this happens to babies and
children not just teenagers and it's not
sex people need to stop using it as the
word sex trafficking it's not sex sex is
consensual between adults this is child
rape trafficking rape and torture it's
so complex and there's so many trillions
of dollars invested in hiding it in
plain sight and for people to have the
emotional capacity to be able to sit
still and consider just one two-year-old
let alone Millions what what is it like
for this one two-year-old
or four-year-old or five-year-old like
people most people don't have the
emotional bandwidth they're like no no I
don't want to hear that
and it's like the and the answer to your
question is everybody needs to do their
inner work a whole lot more so that we
can all collectively awaken and have
create the Sacred Space
I know from from direct experience that
though that there are very real Satanic
rituals and very real programs that go
far beyond what anyone uh most of the
public could ever understand directed by
intelligence agencies and interfacing
with a civilian cover-up of trafficking
homes
um like the one that I was constantly
shuttled back and forth from as a a
cover-up for where I was really being
taken every night
um it's
it's it's a lot for people to take in
when here's the other piece you know
where there the powers that be are
constantly traumatizing the population I
mean look what just happened over the
past few years
um between the lockdowns and the medical
tyranny and you know the the crazy
amount of censorship and closing down of
businesses I mean people are in shock
and they don't even know it and you know
if you look at the news even one day of
the week you're just like oh my God
no one knows where to put their foot
next and so if you keep an entire global
population in a constant state of
anxiety panic and Trauma
it's easy to keep people in a space that
they're not willing to look at these
very real parts of our society that are
actually funding and fueling the level
of luciferian influence over this planet
and over our our population
somewhat surviving not thriving yeah
everyone most people are just surviving
yeah just you're just surviving to some
degree you know and it that we'll just
use that as an easy enough word just to
rhyme with thriving to give it a cool
yeah give it away to say it but like
that's all it is like thriving isn't
recognizing your own power and through
sovereignty which is absolutely what you
teach every single day is personal
sovereignty yeah um you can't have that
when you feel when you're in fear and
when you're in fear you need something
you need someone you need a system you
need other people those that's not
that's not sovereignty it's dependency
it's codependency we have an extremely
codependent Society that's willing to
shame survivors that's willing to look
the other way when power structures tell
them to it's it's there's a massive
Awakening that needs to happen for
people to fully
rise up
what negative entity or energy right now
is is trying to grab this planet and and
and and siphoning the energy from the
humans
luciferianism is a Consciousness and in
my experience as a child subjected to uh
Indescribable torture and and Massacre
atrocities really over and over again in
these
Satanic rituals um it's a Consciousness
that multiple species are connected to
so you know do we want to think about an
actual being you know that's
spearheading the whole thing I mean yes
there are high level beings that you
could point to and say
certain names in that Consciousness but
what's interesting to me is like how
addictive this Consciousness is and how
much it's it's infiltrated and
controlling so many species right now
who are working together for the
persecution and oppression of humanity
most importantly they are working
together so that Humanity won't remember
who we really are
back to Amnesia yeah because humans are
as crazy as it's going to sound our
capacity to feel is so powerful it's
Angelic like our ability to show
unconditional love our ability to
worship whatever we call God our ability
to honor life
um you know the beauty of nature like
we often focus on all of the the shadow
aspect of humanity but the truth is that
our truths our true selves are the
Divinity that's radiating in every cell
of our of our Humanity actually has the
power to create new worlds and to care
for this planet and when mother Mary
teaches in my forthcoming book that I'm
writing right now
um we have the power to harmonize with
other star systems as a collective and
to bring great peace to certain parts of
the universe as a species and you know
if you have multiple species invested in
interstellar War they're certainly not
going to want Humanity to find out about
the power of its heart why is there this
nefarious
intervention or this
what is it that they want like they just
want our energy or like what is it that
what is actually trying to be taken
humans have no idea like if they really
knew like we are purposely uneducated as
a society about the power of the human
body uh kind of the atomic spiritual
power and the the the true potential of
the human body I mean we are literally
toxified day in and day out in this
world for a reason it's because if we
understood the amount of energy power
emotion creativity that we're actually
embodying
um yeah they're just they're just
sucking off of all of that
um
as there were slave race and God did not
create us as a slave race but that's
what we've succumbed to on money levels
yeah
um talked about you just mentioned God
and earlier you're talking about
religion a little bit
um what did Jesus come here to teach us
I mean talk about someone who came to to
teach us everything that we've just been
talking about you know if there was a
teacher on sovereignty it was Jesus you
know because he embodied and we talk
about a lot in the Sophia what we call
Sophia Christ Consciousness and and
that's the Consciousness he always
taught be in this world but not of this
world yeah right why because then you're
you're accessing whatever you call God
or Source or Spirit when you have a
direct when you know you have your
direct connection to that Source you can
download Solutions healing light
intelligence you know anything it's all
available in the field yes it's all
there yeah tune your frequency
absolutely and so you know although it
does seem to refer to a religion there's
a whole
Unity Source movement that has taken the
word Christ back from the from you know
different dogmatic uses in religion to I
to represent like this is how Jesus
walked the Earth how did he perform
these Miracles how did he reach So Many
Lives why are we still talking about him
to this day you know his heart was so
big like what is he embodying for us we
have hearts just like his art and we
need to be using them when you say heart
you mean energy I mean the feeling and
the energy and the Stargate that the
heart chakra is which is also what I'm
writing about
um this year and my journey
um
mother Mary speaks it's um the heart is
a Stargate for the soul so if you are a
walking Stargate and you are checked out
of your body you're not accessing your
heart you're not accessing your true
power to not just change the world
literally transform the world
yeah
birth something totally new it's it's
it's
where what source wants to deliver into
this world it's where it lands at the
very center of your being so it can
radiate out and impact you know every
part of you
how you grounded the Earth how you open
up to the Brilliance of your soul yeah
what about the relationship that Jesus
had with Mary Magdalene and getting into
like the alchemical not only the Divine
masculine feminine Union but then the
alchemical
marriage within the self I know that for
a lot of your audience it's it's not any
new knowledge that you know Jesus was
trained in India and Tibet by Master
extreme Masters masters of the highest
order but so was Mary Magdalene and we
we talk about that in the Sofia code she
came from an extraordinary family
probably one of the richest families
um in Palestine at that time and
um her mother had a secret divine
feminine practice
and her father had a secret mystery
school network so they were both being
trained father yes
so yeah so you know this woman Mary
Magdalene is you know which you know
they wrote total lies about her in the
traditional Bible
um a composite of multiple Mary's that
they lied about in the and so when we
meet Mary magdal and Sophia code we meet
This brilliant psychic
um young woman that was trained as a
high priestess in Egypt as well as India
Mesopotamia temples that
um you know were still operating at that
time her connection to Isis her
connection to segment her connection to
Kali
profound so you know when she finally
met Jesus you know her her spiritual
mother was already mother Mary so mother
Mary was already mentoring her for a
public Ministry that you know women at
the time could be stoned to death for
speaking out loud teach teachings and so
this is I get really excited talking
about their Ministry because it's it's
so special what they did and and it
reads like a movie in the Sofia code and
watching it and channeling it writing it
down was one of the greatest honors of
my life but you know what they don't
write about those fields is that that
Jesus was teaching it was those were the
fields that Mary Magdalene like spent
her Divine in her her inheritance on to
ensure Jesus could actually be teaching
publicly in that way to thousands of
people and she taught him things
meaning she would she would pay for all
of for for creating those experiences
where people could actually show up and
meet thousands of people really like she
was like like she was like yes she
booked events
she kind of produced events yeah
that's a really great way to put it well
she I mean she literally she was given
her inheritance whether she chose to
marry or not like her parents were
absolutely from the future in the sense
of they they were so non-traditional and
they so understood who she was in her
own right as an avatar in Christ to
being and so they let her they let her
be strong in her in her sovereignty of
what she really was there was yeah and
she still had to use her mystery school
training to hide that right because at
this time so it was this interesting
Dynamic where she was so empowered at
home and in her mystery school at Mark
Mount Carmel but then she would have to
go into public with Jesus right and so
she would be teaching side by side with
him they'd both be in full Lotus you
think about these Masters these yogurts
together yeah like yeah it's in the
Sofia code they're sitting side by side
in full Lotus position and they're both
performing exorcisms on the masses side
by side and what Jesus would do and they
we talk about this in Sofia code he
would expand his Consciousness so that
the men and women who would judge her
for being in her full yogic power would
actually protect her so that they could
accept and receive her transmission as a
master in her own right her gifts in
skills were so extraordinary and we call
her she of a Thousand Angels in the
Sofia called she would go forth and send
Angels ahead of Jesus and her arrival to
these fields to clear the Demonic
influences like she was doing shamanic
and then he would like set the field
yeah they were they were crazy he would
like yes he would expand his energy
bubble essentially to protect her while
she was doing her thing but before they
got there she would send the angels to
clear the space from
evil demonic energies that would
interfere with the work I mean they were
they were doing high priest and high
priestess work of the highest Magi order
the highest order so when people you
know not all but a lot of people talk
lightly about Mary magdalene's path with
Tantra with Jesus in him just like uh-uh
you had no idea the level of Magic the
level of
um training and Mastery and and how they
were consciously working together as
masters of light for thousands of people
to be transformed from the luciferian
grip of their day like they were so
selfless they were so loving they were
so intelligent they were so creative
they were so psychic it was so far
beyond like this is my boyfriend Jesus
you know what I mean it was like are you
kidding me like sit down and close your
eyes yeah I'm like they were doing they
were leading a movement that was saving
the planet I mean people you would walk
basically I literally like imagine
walking down the street and just have
the streets lined with people being
crucified I mean that was the form of
Roman punishment of the day it wasn't
reserved for someone like Jesus it it
was just everywhere wherever they lived
you would see people strung up on
crosses so like we we have this idea
that it was like a once in a while thing
it was like this is the kind of extreme
torture the Roman Empire was using to
oppress
um you know the different countries that
they that they would um take over and so
the Jewish people were living under such
extreme tyrannical conditions not to
mention that they already had extreme
conditions at the time for women being
in their power you know so it's like
women were property and if a woman did
anything out of line out of the Pharisee
codes it was just like they could
literally be stoned to death at any
point so the fact that Mary Magdalene
and Jesus were using
what is high level Tantra high level
Tantra I mean can it be experienced
through sexual Union absolutely but it
is the sexual Union is not the
definition of Tantra Tantra is when we
experience total communion with all that
is total communion with the Earth total
communion with your Divinity total
communion with every cell of your body
total God communion Source communion
Universal communion you have two
individuals that are embodying total
communion and presence and then you and
then within the relationship with one
another they are doing such
extraordinary things with their human
bodies it destroys any concept that we
have of what Tantra is and whatever we
think our modern context is and the
reason why I speak so passionately about
it is because I feel strange even
talking about it out loud because what
they were doing was so holy brings tears
to my apps like it is so pure like it is
the definition of what Isis talks about
in the Sophia code about you know your
sexuality being a pathway to recognizing
your true Divinity we're not talking
about you feeling better about your
self-esteem or like you're you know
having a an ego lift we're talking about
God communion and what are you gonna do
with that God communion in your
sexuality in Your Divine Purpose in your
creativity in your service to the light
in your service to Humanity's Awakening
to a sovereignty that that is that's
that is the Tantra of full beingness
these people started training at the age
of three or four like we have to
understand it's interesting that the
Bible actually reveals Jesus like
teaching in the temple at the age of 12.
you know it's like they were already
adults by 12 13 14. they've been
training since childhood for their
Ministries you know not that they stop
their training in their early
adolescence it continued but we have to
understand like activating the full
chakra system activating the full full
Kundalini system allowing the true and
full activation of the Divine genome to
integrate within every cell of our body
like that takes Focus
it takes time it's not a weekend warrior
Workshop we've got to be willing to do
the internal emotional and inner work
that matches that kind of spiritual
technology Awakening within our body
because if you you go ahead and try to
awaken different parts of that spiritual
technology without doing the inner work
you're not going to know what to do with
an erupting Kundalini Awakening not
gonna know what's happening if one
chakra is blasted open and the others
aren't so it's not in Balance
so this is why I have so much respect
for for their relationship and what they
did together
um and what they continue to do together
you know after magdalene's escape and
they had children right a common theme
as the three children
um
I think what's important for people to
understand is
what Mary Magdalene Jesus always wanted
was for us to focus on
their example as our own potential
and so we don't want to get lost in the
details of their legacy in that way
because it's so much easier to just be
in the fantasy of what they did right is
this alchemical Union this this like
is that something that you go in too
much with being like the one within
yourself because I feel like we're kind
of just fractal everything's quite
fractal and all the same so we're trying
to find like how to be together as a man
and a woman or two people but like
there's also the parallel to the self
right and the masculine feminine within
so can you talk about that alchemical
Union within the self and like what what
you need to do to achieve that yeah you
can only go so high in your alchemical
union with another based on how high
you're going with yourself yeah exactly
you know that's kind of what I was
referring to earlier too is like how
does this analogy work with regular
people versus your experience to get the
information because yeah yes you can
only go as you can only receive as far
as you as you rise I think a lot of
people don't realize that you can
cultivate
what you feel through your sensuality
and your sexuality and you can you can
move that incredible fire throughout
your entire body for your creativity
or you're messaging for breaking through
old patterns and releasing yourself from
old blockages and resistances and and
for deepening in a very intimate
relationship when I say intimate I mean
like that God communion with your own
heart through self-love self-compassion
and that cultivation
opens your awareness eventually to all
the lifetimes you've lived information
that you need for the zero calibration
of your soul like bringing in the gifts
and the talents and even the
even the the lifetimes of Enlightenment
that you may have lived in other
lifetimes to bring them to gather all
that those
energy energetic imprints the gifts and
the tools from those other lifetimes to
embody them now so we need all of
ourself now so that outcome alchemical
Union with yourself
is a big part of how we can kind of suit
up as lightworkers
or our Angelic Mission this lifetime
gives it gets it's the pathway to
getting all of the parts of ourselves
back how do we know we've achieved
some level of it or it well you start to
notice
how many lives that you're touching
[Music]
then you start to notice even with just
one life like the light that's radiating
out from you that's
has the power to lift somebody else up
and then you start to realize that that
love
and that light is what all of this is
about
and you stop
searching and seeking as much for all of
the sexy glamorous stuff and you start
getting really serious about embodying
that transformational love for yourself
and others as the highest point of
Spiritual Awakening because you reach a
certain level on spiritually and you're
like oh that was all the Glamorous stuff
that enticed me to awaken to the real
stuff
the feeling is it becomes a lot more of
an inside job and
there's less to say like the further you
get there's a lot there's like the
beginning it's kind of it's kind of
outward you're kind of doing these
things you're out here you're doing that
you're doing this thing or yeah like but
then as it goes it becomes this quiet
knowing or this quiet awareness that
isn't necessarily for the glamor it's
just for your own glamorous [__]
reality that you live in that you've
you've you've earned and you don't need
to there's nothing to say it's just
something you live and you realize that
you have a responsibility to keep
creating that beautiful reality for the
liberation of all beings it's not just
about you
I would really like you if you would
indulge us to go into the eight key
codes the ascended masters and
just kind of give a little like high
level of like what their message is and
um so people can get a little exposure
to those ascended masters and
um and um some great takeaways to feel
more comfort and know that there's so
much so there are so so much energy here
that has our back so many so many
resources to Source from
um by by telling us what they're what
their what their hope is and their
messages oh I love that thanks Danica
um so of course we start with Isis and
Isis in her initiation what's happening
there is Isis helps us clear a lot of
Oaths and vows for some of us thousands
of lifetimes of you know we we pick up a
lot of wounding along the path of having
a soul and we make a lot of agreements
that keep us small instead of in our
full power to other species to other
lifetimes to other religious agreements
that would keep us from being in our
full Sovereign power so when we're
stepping into mentorship with Isis where
she's helping us get really serious
about the truth that we're extremely
powerful and how to get sober from our
fears about that and how to fully like
embrace it Isis for me is all about like
stepping in Your Divine Purpose your
message you're offering
um getting important projects completed
also knowing that you can be in your
power with your your in the center of
your family structure and your
relationship
whether you're a partnership especially
but also how you relate to others
um
she's she's very relationship oriented
because she knows that relationships are
how anything gets done here on the Earth
plane so she's gonna help you look at
all the ways that you might be afraid to
relate to others which could help you
step more into your power
really interesting yeah and she's also
extremely glamorous so a lot her along
with Mary Magdalene they're great
mentors for reclaiming the divine
feminine like adorning yourself loving
your body Letting Go shame conditioning
um you know being in your full feminine
yeah I feel feminine and this is for men
too it's just she she's really a mentor
for how you present yourself to the
world and then it's safe to be powerful
hot Thor we take a pretty significant
jump with hathor
Isis was one of hathor's greatest
initiates and um Hawthorne created a
mystery school when she walked the Earth
that spanned half the planet
wow yeah so when we're when we're
talking about where's your school um
everywhere
yeah so you know when Heather walked the
Earth
um we're we are living uh in a different
kind of potential
um you could call it an extreme golden
age and hathor took that golden age to
an entirely new level you know in the
Sofia code we share how she was at her
Mystery Schools hosting
um ceremonies and initiations with
teachers from the serious star system
they were shape-shifting to reveal
Humanity's full potential to shapeshift
themselves and use their DNA like that
form is actually quite pliable and
flexible really hard Just Energy yeah so
you know her teachings are all about our
Quantum potential and and really in the
Sofia code what you're doing is
um she's the one initiation where we're
quite consciously it's happening in
every initiation but she spells it out
you actually activate the bridges of
light from the Bridget from the edges of
your DNA the ladders of your DNA to the
Divine genome and the subatomic Universe
of your DNA so I had to really go deep
with hathor to understand these Divine
genome teachings that the Sofia code
presents and actually
um I just had the most amazing
conversation with uh
yeah oh my God he's so brilliant he
actually had information that I had seen
that a channel that's so cool
I don't know he owns a company called
the DNA company yes you can get your
basically your DNA read to like what
pathways are open closed how your
hormones work but like yes it is so
informational and so just for people so
they can go into it if they want but yes
kashup is brilliant
we're having this conversation the other
night because of you thank you and
um he's like the most amazing person I
have so much respect for his work and
his mind and
um and he was saying well you know this
one part about how light works with DNA
and I said wait wait wait like you know
I've never heard I've never seen that in
any you know book on on DNA and and you
know Western science and he's like oh
that's because it's not there
but it was like it's it's it's only what
the elite would know and I was just like
you guys were words I said the words you
just said I've been saying those words
for 10 years Building Bridges of light
from
the biological DNA to the Divine genome
within subatomic Universe of our
genetics and so that was an
extraordinary moment for me and it's
really hathor that you know being Guided
by hathor that kind of initiated me to
have the courage to come forward with
those teachings at a time where I knew I
could improve it like I still don't I
still can't prove it but I know that
it's true and I know that it's real
because I risked everything to share
that message with the world well you
know there's a great there's a great
scene in um Contact the movie and it's
where Jody Foster and Matthew
McConaughey like ones she's all science
and he's all spirituality and he's
challenging her and he says did you love
your dad because her dad died when she
was young and she goes of course and he
goes prove it
um
and you can't like what how are you
gonna prove you love your dad or your
mom or your someone like yeah you can't
you just know it you just freaking know
it
well it's funny you brought up that
example because it was my love for
Humanity that
Humanity's future that you know I how
could I say no to the Master's request
to share that information it was because
of love that I I risked being a fool to
share that with the world and
you know what I love about hathor is
that I believe hathor's teachings within
Sofia code are really getting us ready
for Interstellar communion with beings
of the highest light
um not not the beings that are currently
oppressing the planet but but our our
star Families Our ancient families from
across the Multiverse that are just
waiting for enough of humanity to wake
up that we can
have that deep Tundra communion right
with all that is including other species
that are extremely enlightened and ready
to such as the hathor Star Nation that
are ready to help us step into a much
brighter future
so
um and it should be said too that the
booking is has key code DNA activations
like things that you say out loud not
only reading the book is an activation
but maybe go into that just a little
just so people know that as we're
talking about DNA I mean think the
people just like for a second just go we
are all energy if you put all the people
on the planet together and put together
their actual matter I just heard I when
I interviewed Dylan deGrasse Tyson he
said you know whatever size Apple the
other day I heard it was the size of a
sugar cube the point is all all the
human beings actual real matter put
together on the planet is freaking
nothing we are Just Energy so now go
into please just like like just what the
the role of the activations yeah so in
my really early Journey
um when I was in uh College I was
studying computer programming for
animation and design
yeah yeah I have a my degree is in is in
you know web and branding and and
actually animation and
um
and I always wondered like
okay am I is this
am I supposed to go deeper and deeper
into this back you know program hard
coding and
um and I and I got the message no and I
was like but why why am I so interested
in it and they were like it'll be
revealed you know down down the road
so when I first saw the Divine genome
you know all these years in seclusion
meditating with the ascended masters
I realized that the Sophia code was
actually hard-coded it needed to be
initiations that were hard coding to
literally flip on the switches that
would connect the Divine genome to the
carbon-based DNA and that the Brilliance
of the Sophia Dragon tribe was that they
wanted people to do this through the
power of their own voice oh I just got
chills because the the power of your own
voice is actually what activates Your
Divine genome this this bridge of light
connection these crystalline bridges of
light that you can consciously connect
and not only connect but they become a
super highway
for the Divinity of your higher self to
start downloading like an operating
system into the interface of the Divine
genome with then is now connected as
versions of light to the human body and
because it's crystalline there's no
amount of light it's like an infinite
amount of light that can be downloaded
into your body and over time this is why
Saints starts to literally like glow
right like you see pictures of like
Ananda moyman she's like glowing or
paramahansa Yogananda and they look like
there's light coming out of their skin
it's because there is they they found a
way to activate their Divine genome and
and this this technology has the power
to Anchor and an infinite amount of God
Source light in your body and we all
have this power we all have this
potential and so what they showed me is
the throat chakra you know the power of
your throat chakra the resonance which
mother Mary talks about in actually
hathor's chapter so we're still talking
about hathor has the power on this
bottom victory of your throat chakra
two um it's what creates reality through
the power of your voice this one little
petal at the bottom of your throat
chakra stop it the resonance that comes
through your voice through this one
little part of your throat chakra and
that resonance
um you know when you start to that's why
hathor and the Sofia code is called she
of a thousand voices which she is
attempting to to activate within
humanity is that we all have this voice
to create reality
and so when we start to notice and feel
the shifts of the Divine genome
operating our human body and our human
awareness in new ways then we make the
Cognitive Connection oh my God I did
that
I'm Sovereign if I can do that what else
can realize your power yeah and so these
initiations do two things simultaneously
they initiate Your Divine genome which
then starts an operating system that
simultaneously starts clearing viral
programming and Trauma from all your
lifetimes simultaneously while also
Begins the downloading process of your
higher self within every cell of your
body no big deal kind of the everything
and it's like it and then there's this
reinforcement of the each of these
ascended masters as you complete their
initiation they're saying I now commit
to you as a mentor and a spiritual guide
for what it's going to take to live in
these Divine qualities that you're now
going to go on a journey of embodying in
your daily life and so
um that's what's happening and the
recordings of the initiations help
reinforce and help you deepen and
integrate and accept the Divine genome
operating your awareness your ego
because what happens is you have to go
through an ego structure meltdown right
like it's got to start yeah they're fun
yeah it's got to start to integrate with
the light of your higher self and that's
why people start a spiritual journey and
they're like and then they end up giving
up because like this this is miserable
it's too hard right yeah it's not all
[__] puppies and rainbows no they are
skulls and flaming swords involved in a
true Spiritual Awakening and meltdowns
like like Rising Phoenix man over and
over again
so when you invoke that much light you
you also are becoming more aware of the
darkness that's been waiting for you to
see inside of yourself and so these
initiations really start the process of
allowing enough light to come and
override the ego structures demands on
your awareness and what you're going to
do with your life and it starts to break
the chains of the programming that would
have you forget who you are and start
the process of remembering who you
really are so
it's not any surprise that they put
Green Tara after hathor because
Green Tara who ascended in the star
system serious and then was invited by
the Divine mother to help shut like
oversee Humanity's Awakening on this
planet
um she is a total expert on how to
overcome the ego structure and how
devastating the ego structure and how
Wily it is it can you know what it takes
to outwit it through love self-love and
self-compassion and so
she's extraordinary I could talk about
Tara for hours but um for the sake of
time
um she helps us really see both our
Sovereign potential and our attachments
to suffering and
her Angelic order are called the dakinis
and they're often like these pictured of
these radical wrathful deities divine
feminine Buddhas that come forward to
protect you from you
to protect you from your own sabotage so
if you call on Green Tara to to help guy
to be your guide to help you in this
journey she's going to send Extra
Protection
yeah I mean she alone is right
larger I mean she's called the mother of
all Buddhas but that says anything
so you know it's like all of Buddhism
came from Tara's arrival to this planet
it didn't it's amazing how much the
divine feminine gets kind of written out
of it all right exactly every foot is a
guy right yeah well and and and and and
you know they do teach the zucchinis are
a female Buddhas but it's amazing kind
of
I won't go into all of that I want to
stay really positive but what I love
about Tara and then dakinis and the
Sofia code is the full Reclamation of
the divine feminine transmission that
gave birth to Buddhism on this planet
there it is yeah there it is plain and
simple there it is so
um and then we move into mother Mary
right and each of these Kiko initiations
are connected to a chakra so here we
have mother Mary at the heart chakra
and uh mother Mary is a spiritual mother
that we've always wanted we meet her in
the Sofia code free of religious
Doctrine for everyone which is dogma and
what people don't know about Mother Mary
they think of mother Mary's like this
little girl in the major scene right
I think mother Mary gets to speak like
four times in the Bible at the most and
it's not much
um
and the truth is that mother Mary was
initiated into the mysteries of very
early age her mother was an extreme High
Priestess of hathor she was an oracle
Anna
um hi hi princess of hathor trained in
Egypt and so Mary was born to one of the
most powerful oracles on the planet at
that time
her mother knew
exactly who she was giving birth to and
she gave birth to Mary Mary was an
extraordinary orator she she was a
Divine feminist speaker yeah it's like a
speaker of the highest level
um divine feminine teacher of the
greatest Mysteries of the heart
um you know her mentors in communion and
Tantra communion and her psychic
development or Isis and hathor and Green
Tara and Kuan Yin I mean she led a
mystery school with her mother that
trained you know Jesus and Mary
Magdalene I mean not saying something an
entire community that you know embraced
them and their Ministry it wasn't just
Jesus and Magdalene and Mary that were
you know changing transforming the world
there were so many initiates embodying
their Divinity at that time and
um and that's you know she was a
spiritual mother to marry me Mary
Magdalene was so fiery you know yeah she
was like the Indigo she's like the
Indigo the ascended Master World she's
just like I don't you know she wanted to
break all the rules you know she just
wanted to go right after the Roman
Empire you know with all of her psychic
gifts and burn everything down and of
course like she just had that Kalima
sekhmet righteous rage for her people
and that's how we meet her in her
chapter just this
raw beautiful powerful areas yeah it
must have been right
she was just um
she was just wow she was a while and uh
you know I love that the Sofia code
talks about her relationship with Mother
Mary and that there was this true like
spiritual
Legacy between
magdalene's family mother Mary's family
Jesus and Magdalene there's Anna like
this connection to Egypt Tibet and and
India and
um so Magdalene is
we get to meet Mary Magdalene
as Magdalene like of course Jesus is
there and their Ministry is there but
what's so important to me about how we
meet Magdalene and the Sofia code is we
get to meet her
so many people introduce Magdalene in
context to the other
how she is defined by her relationship
to Jesus how is she defined by her
relationship with her sexuality it's
like in the Sofia code she's defined for
the woman that she is as the angel in
human form that she is as you know
as the head of a movement
totally transform the world yes
alongside the ha you know someone else
who's the head of a movement as well
they co-let a movement of Grace and
lightning and thunder and Consciousness
radical Consciousness and so she teaches
us that we are all awakeners of that
same Consciousness and that we've got to
be willing to embody that same Angelic
light that they did that she actually
shares in Sofia code we are a
continuation of their mission and if you
are attracted to Mary Magdalene is
because you've been a Magdalene for many
many lifetimes like Magdalene is a title
it's those Souls that are willing to
bring their light into the darkest of
places for their radical transformation
and Awakening of a species and so Mary
Magdalene helps us open our angel wings
and own them love her oh God and
everything else that goes along with it
I mean each of them are like a whole
universe of a wealth of resources I'm
trying to sum them up Quan Yin
I
I don't know I don't know which is I I
venture to say it's my most favorite
chapter in the Sofia code it reads um it
reads like a movie
and we meet Kuan Yin as a child
um when her Village is attacked
and she is
um
raped and tortured and her family is
killed in front of her
and her Village is burned to the ground
and then we go on a journey with her
into the jungle of her grief
where
her Divine masculine counterpart appears
to help awaken the divine feminine
Christ Consciousness within her
and what it took for her to heal
in the witnessing of the Divine
masculine on this journey of self-love
self-compassion painful self-compassion
painful embracing of the full journey of
healing from trauma into Soul power
and then what happens at the end where
she
he ascends in front of her and then she
gets to become this Larger than Life
teacher of compassion true and authentic
Awakening to compassion the power of
that compassion and she teaches in
Sophia code she is here to Mentor those
divine feminine leaders that are here in
this lifetime that are here to lead
through authentic self-compassion for
themselves first so this diamond of
compassion teachings is Diamond vehicle
from Kuan Yin comes in at key code six
we've got this building of like you know
Isis and hathor and green tar like super
powerful and let's go and mother Mary is
like let's open your heart and get into
here and magdalene's like get into your
leadership and all of a sudden
we're staring eye to eye with Kuan yin
and all this inner child healing and
this Kiko's sixth initiation where your
inner child
flows down this River to meet Kuan Yin
under this beautiful
um willow tree
and you have this oh my God and you have
this huge conversation an activation of
the Phoenix child oh my god this is my
chapter
with the Invincible innocence
this is like a Rising Phoenix painting
this is then this is for you right the
the Invincible innocence within you that
was never touched or harmed by anything
that you have survived in this lifetime
you feel that too don't you I mean
that's probably why it's one of your
favorite chapters yeah I mean it was one
of the hardest chapters for me to
surrender into because that was I I had
so much healing from everything I
survived and the first half in my life
and
um
and yet it's I think it's the most
beautiful it's it's uh
that to meet your Phoenix child and to
realize that that it is the master of
light that you are invoking within you
like it is your future
self it is your ascended Master self
that always existed within you that
could survive anything without your soul
you know being taken from you source of
your sovereignty and your Purity that
can never be touched
so this chapter is where most people
like totally break down and weep and
have the biggest breakthroughs of their
life and and and what I love about this
is that it really I think there's a lot
of people out there thinking that they
can just do this spiritual Divine
Purpose leadership rah-rah thing like I
don't know like you know from like a
headspace where if we just achieve
enough we'll get there
but
it's this is a like an authentic path of
spiritual weakening has to be from that
genuine space of where you know the most
broken places within you
which is hard to go to
because it's from that place that you
can compassionately serve anyone
no matter what they have survived no
matter how triggered their egos are you
can see yourself in them because you are
brave enough to love the one within you
that that once reacted or once you know
did the same things that someone else is
doing right in front of you it's like
leadership is service
and spiritual true authentic Spiritual
Awakening is Awakening to the truth that
we're here to love one another the way
Jesus taught
you know to really see each other's
potential means we gotta hold the line
and hold the bar high for each other
yeah and when people say I am my trauma
we have to say no you're not no you're
more than your trauma and that's what
kuanian mentors are saying yeah and I
know it because I lived it I'm not
asking you to believe me because I
didn't go with them to find out from
myself you know kuanian brings some
humility then into into the picture that
I think is is a beautiful Temperance to
how ex to the unlimited power that we're
accessing here in the Sophia code um
within our hearts and our divine genome
and White Buffalo Woman comes in at the
at key code seven and holy smokes
um like channeling that chapter I took a
lot I took many years of training in the
Native American Church to understand why
white buffalo women had come and asked
me to to do this and I include her why
did she well for starters she's the only
ascended master in this planet that is
native to this planet so you're saying
that all the other ascended masters they
come from other star systems mother star
systems
so she came from this star system where
she started her journey on this planet
she's like a she's like a combo she's a
combo
kind of like an archangel Fender being
slash ascended Master because she does
touch she has touched down in human form
therefore we can oriented is she more
like planetary nature
oriented or is she he's a master of the
source of original Source teachings
found within every indigenous culture on
the planet
so she's overseeing
the treasure
of Earth of Earth wisdom that is
absolutely essential essential for
Humanity's Ascension
this was her like uh when they say Gaia
like the planet got the like
um what what is her relationship with
with the Earth's consciousness
well I mean she's a part of
tending to its ecosystem
she's a part of
protecting
the heart of mother earth like the
spiritual consciousness of Mother Earth
and communicating the wisdom and
um and also she's part of an Angelic
order that we call in the Sofia go the
order of Sky grandmothers is extremely
Ancient Ancient Ancient ancestors that
have been watching over the Earth's
Ascension like we as a species have an
Ascension path but so does the Earth
okay yeah yeah the planet has its own
Ascension Journey as well what's
panchamama
well that that would be connected to the
traditions of yeah how they would refer
to the Earth and the Earth lineages in
in South America Central America
many names for the same Consciousness
um so
yeah
one of the things that that white
buffalo women
um initiates Us in in the Sofia code is
stepping into the power of a Christ
admission
so one of the weirdest things that
happened to me in the Sofia code was the
cinemasters kept saying they wanted me
to use the word Christ for Christ
Consciousness in the book and I was like
I don't want to do that that's so
religiony
like please don't make me do that I feel
so uncomfortable with that
um and so I I would write it in but I
kept reserving the the right to
eventually find another word or edit it
out or I don't know I just I just kept I
there was such a resistance there and it
was actually White Buffalo Woman
oh my God I'll never forget this
so there's a teacher
um
a coded teacher who was named Black Elk
and
um he shares his version of white
buffalo women's
um return or
visit to his people where she brings the
sacred pipe to Earth physically descends
from heaven and there's this whole story
um
it's that was passed down for per
Generations
when I was reading through it in his
book The Sacred pipe
I was like wait a minute everything
about this story is Messianic it
literally has all the same Christian
principles of a messiah figure
prophecies that must come true
for that Messianic Messenger to fulfill
the prophecies that they spoke and
here's the thing her prophecies came
true her prophecy was that in the age
that her Consciousness would Return to
the Planet The White Buffalo would
appear upon the Earth as an emanation of
her grace and in our lifetime The White
Buffalo
which are an entirely new genetic
species have appeared upon the planet
they're not albino they're not bred to
be there are at least 20 truly totally
new genetic White Buffalo on the planet
held by Cynthia Golden Bear now I know
why you love white buffalo so much yeah
and I've had the Good Fortune of meeting
them and working with Cynthia and they
are truly prophecy animals and so white
buffalo said to me she said look my
people the the First Nations people were
genocided in the name of Christianity
and there is no greater Reclamation for
people to understand the Holiness of my
teachings than to talk about them in
terms of Christ Consciousness because
that's exactly what I've been teaching
all along and so there was this really
interesting language Dynamic that came
in where she was like I need people to
understand that the iraqular
languaging of mystical Christian
tradition which is you know
predates the organized Roman religion
the oracular
things that we look to in Mystic
initiations is exactly what white
buffalo woman's appearance and her
teachings that she brought to the people
as well as her Ascension and her
prophecies coming true they're literally
like they follow the formula of what is
prescribed in Mystic judaic tradition
for a messiah figure and that just blew
my hair back I was just like whoa okay
so what is White Buffalo women really do
in here she's initiating us into our our
own
Sovereign Christ Hood we are all
christed beings in the eyes of God we
are all Divine
and so or you could say Buddha beings
that are Awakening to the truth of our
of our our true nature and so she really
um she's really about the collective
Mission so by the time you reach key
code seven if you get that far I wish I
hope hope you do
um it's like game on you are wondering
what is my Divine Purpose and how am I
here to serve so in the final in the
eighth initiation which is actually key
code 777
um
I wonder why it took seven years to
download those huh really and you're
summing it up in a short amount of time
40 minutes oh my gosh
we meet the holiest seraphim of the
Divine mother we meet these Angelic
beings and the Kabbalah the seraphim are
called the fiery creatures of God
and I knew and I found that piece of
information because it was really
extraordinary for me to see
these angelic
holy creatures that were dragons they
weren't dragons connected to this world
they weren't dragons connected to any
Planet they were
these holy creatures of God that were
singing at the Throne of the Divine
mother's Consciousness whatever
that in that space
where the nothingness the no thing the
black womb of no thing turns into the
light of creation that to me is the
heart the Sacred Heart of divine mother
and at that place that's where those
seraphim are singing
an assisting creation
to come into form according to a Divine
will
and so they are initiators of our
Consciousness to recognize that we have
the power to co-create with Divine will
and to live as Jesus taught in this
world but not of this world fully
activated and living in our Highest
Potential to create a new Sovereign
reality because Dragon medicine yeah
it's like
dragons are masters of both Heaven and
Earth it's so appropriate that this
energy is coming in at this time to help
us overcome the luciferian interstellar
war that we're facing like we would need
protectors we would need activators at
this level of sovereignty that was
insanely insightful and inspiring and
hopeful
take us into where we're going like
where does this take us what's the
what's the we do the work so that we can
live in what reality well I I feel like
we kind of started there yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what would happen if everybody
was living in their full Divine
potential what if creative genius was
accepted and not attacked
what if you know we found solutions that
didn't match The Narrative of the
science of the day
what if we what if quantum leaps were an
everyday miracle
like what if we lived in a world where
our food was radiating with everything
that we need to put in our bodies what
if we lived in a world where it was so
healthy we didn't even need to eat half
the food we think we do oh yeah right
right exactly what if we lived in a
world where we were allowed to you know
choose a pathway of goodness that
allowed for us to stand up for what we
know
life wants to create through us which is
Beauty and Grace and compassion and
enlightenment it's like this is all
possible it is all possible but
the inner work is required to unplug
from everything that would keep you from
enjoying
that Paradigm here on the Earth plane
you do Retreats and you do events so I
mean if you know if people are still
listening I'm gonna have no doubt that
they're gonna be really curious about
how to go deeper and one way is the book
um and their own practice their own
personal practice but
um what can they do to get even closer
and learn even more
um from yeah we would love to invite
um anyone who's listening to come join
us in France
um this summer we'll be in Marseille
France uh for a Magdalene heart
immersive we also have a full mystery
school which is um in a very soon to be
available on our phone app the Sofia
code app that you can download for your
Android or Apple
um and those chat those curriculums have
all been channeled to support uh every
step of embodied Awakening so and we
also have a beautiful
um
we have an incredible community of
certified leaders that can also take
people on Sophia Circle Journeys through
the book in community
um so there's just so many Pathways to
join us including this year we're doing
a live journey through my next book
mother Mary speaks on how to open your
heart which we couldn't be more
important than right now because of that
Stargate creative power that we were
speaking about earlier so thanks for
allowing me to share it's all oh my God
kyra.com my website so there's such a
little angel it's a little he's such a
such a warrior too I mean you know the
life that you've come through and the
lessons that you've had to learn the
hard way and and endure and be find
strength from and grow from learn from
and uh is um
amazing and uh you're gonna get a lot of
people that want to pick your book up
now so
thanks Danica it's so great to be here
with you today
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button